little elves goblins Pixies completely
new forms of experience are these just
hallucinations was there some reality in
them
is what is real is that fundamentally
physical
there's a lot of philosophers here today
who believe that's good
um or is it mental is that and it so
that would be candy cant for example I
mentioned Shelby now and so on um or is
it both physical and mental or do they
have the same fundamentality that is
mind matter dualism
um or is it uh something Beyond both
something underlying both and they they
sort of emerge from that neutral
substance neutral monism
um or there's another type of um Duality
as well from Plato which is that you
know there's a special physical world
but there's also a Transcendent world of
ideals forms in metaphysics as well as
that there are questions about causation
about form space and time the Eternal
qualities properties relations
modalities like necessity probability
potentiality and so on and when I mean
I've taught metaphysics at Exeter and
that's kind of very hard-nosed logical
stuff which doesn't really pertain
immediately to psychedelics but we've
tried to in Exeter create a matrix of
metaphysical points of view and there's
sort of one draft of it it's not
exhaustive sometimes so we had to do
this cross-sectioning because for
example with a paper that I mentioned
um where psychedelics shift run from
physicalism to pan psychism the problem
with that sometimes is that pan psychism
is sometimes defined as physicalism
right from for example Galen strawson
and sometimes you can get dualists pan
psychisms and so on and so forth so
we've tried to create a matrix which is
a bit more comprehensive than what has
been used hither too even though it's
not perfect it's very hard actually to
differentiate these isms the question
we'll consider today is how does one
understand psychedelic experiences under
each of these ontological options do
psychedelic experiences lean towards any
specific ontology how do metaphysics
inform psychedelics and how do
psychedelics inform metaphysics if they
do
but what are psychedelic experiences
first thing to note is that there's an
overlap here rather than an identity so
um
psychedelic experiences can be
metaphysical I'll explain that in a
moment what I mean by that
um and they can be mystical and
mysticism is not exactly the same as
metaphysics and psychedelic experiences
can be neither metaphysical or nor
mystical so for example if you take
psychedelics and you see uh
kaleidoscopic colors that wouldn't
really be uh thought of as metaphysical
or mystical metaphysics you know if you
did this if you're in my metaphysics
class you wouldn't think anything's
related to mysticism or psychedelics
more about logic really and with
mysticism you might get like uh let's
say the study of um Theresa of Avila
right it's theological Traditions which
don't really fit that well into either
of the others so we should differentiate
these three fields for a start so I'm
not saying that all psychedelic
experiences are metaphysical absolutely
not but psychedelic there's a vast array
of psychedelic experiences and I'll go
through some of them in a moment this
book uh coming out in a few weeks edited
by me and Christine housekiller by Blue
Bloomsbury is has 15 essays and we talk
about the wide typology of these States
from a number of different views but
let's give you a few examples this from
bordelaire whom I mentioned so
synesthesia can be incurred through
psychedelics so quote ideas are
distorted perceptions are confused
sounds are clothed in colors and colors
of music musical notes become numbers
you feel yourself Vanishing Into Thin
Air and you attribute to your pipe the
strange ability to smoke you for example
jaegon Kim who's a great fluster of mine
he died a year or two ago um not related
to psychedelics experiences other than
through me but he he
do you write this book called
physicalism or something near enough and
um you really pulls out the problems of
that particular ontology which is the
default ontology for clinical trials
today one interesting question what
point he makes is this that why are just
these qualia I don't like the words but
you know colors redness blueness tastes
of Marmite or whatever and why do we
have just these quality and not other
possible ones that remains a mystery in
other words why is um certain Electric
Man magnetic frequencies
um that are possibly processed in the
occipital lobe why do they appear as red
why not as a sound or as something else
or as a taste why do we have just these
colors why not more
um there's no real reason why we have
the phenomenology we do except to
differentiate things but that could be
differentiated in different ways now I
mentioned this here because it's quite
interesting that
a lot of psychedelic experiences seem to
induce novel qualia like completely new
forms of experience that for which there
are no Concepts no terms no
classifications and that's why partly I
believe
um as we shall see William James said
one of the four criteria
for mysticism was ineffability which
means you cannot put it into words
because we've never we just haven't got
haven't experienced these things as a
community to make words for them
they're not always Pleasant I'm not
going to say psychedelics are always
great for you they can be highly
disturbing here's an example this from
Richard Ward is a great book from 1957
on LSD phenomenology called a drug
taker's notes anyway in that for example
he wrote this it is impossible to convey
the horror of thus being threatened with
sheer nothingness the Fear of Infinity I
wish that I had the courage to try to
find out where one is if one is nowhere
but metaphysical horror is kind of like
a pushed form of the sublime if you've
studied that in Aesthetics you know
it just reminds me of another report I
read once where so I think it was LSD as
well someone said they found themselves
in this suddenly in in this uh space it
was hardly space and this nothingness
and that and they they thought they'd
never come out and then they heard a
voice at least but it said not only will
you be here forever you never even
existed in the first place
this was believed so even though
psychedelics for the most part are not
physiologically damaging they can be
psychologically very distressful
actually
certain ones such as 5mio DMT which I
will talk about and at the end but they
are
super powerful and they involve a lot of
integration to fully accept so I
although I'm talking about for
psychedelics I am not promoting their
use without proper consideration
apparent Life review there's LST this is
from a lover sax a book hallucinations
then my whole life flash in my mind from
birth to the present with every detail
that ever happened every feeling of
thought Visual and emotional was there
in an instant um interesting Thomas
Quincy whom I mentioned with opium also
said that with high dose of opium he
could go back in time and relive parts
of his life for example when he was a
child in Exquisite detail which led him
to claim that he therefore believes that
memories are never lost everything is
retained just access to them is lust and
a lot of clinical therapy on
psychedelics is related to
um going back to your past with a
psychotherapist and reliving these
traumatic moments to overcome them this
can go horribly wrong though and I can
talk about that privately later another
one the classic is from Rick Strassman
who wrote DMT The Spirit Molecule it's
very influential also made into a film
as I accepted my death into solution
into God's love the insectoids began to
feed on my heart devouring the feelings
of love and surrender they feasted as
they made love to me it was extremely
alien but not necessarily unpleasant
there you go
they look like Jokers they were almost
performing for me girls on that big
noses however I had the feeling they
could turn on me a little lesson
completely friendly so intra this is a
big mystery for me is one thing I just
can't work out right he's a lilliputians
little people there are so many reports
and they predate Terence McKenna
um of uh seeing Little People little
elves goblins Pixies little people who
are a bit a little bit dangerous right
very common why I have no clue it does
really odd
um uh David that apparently has got a
new theory on it he was asked a few
weeks ago and he says he's gonna come
out with he didn't dare to tell anyone
yet it's so amazing apparently he's
worked on that but
um I I look forward to that
the question is
the the really important question is
David Luke also is a specialist in this
um who's from Greenwich University but
the interesting question is are these
just hallucinations was there some
reality in them and what level of
reality so could there be for example
representations of your psyche
or
um could they be real you know could
they have their own point of view
I don't know I'm not going to talk about
that because I don't know the answer to
it so I'm going to talk about this I
don't really have the answer to this
either but
um another type of excited experience is
the modest you could say roughly
speaking the modest experience this is
the Alan Watts on it for example
um the individual discovers himself to
be one continuous process with god with
the universe to those who have known it
it is as real and overwhelming as
Falling in Love
from the joyous cosmology I think
so um the modest experience in other
words mind a matter are one and also
nature and God are one this obviously
relates to Spinoza if you know anything
about him in a minute
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit IAI dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas